[Music]
this Summit is ready for everyone uh
because a design thinking mindset uh is
not specific to a designer uh but design
mindset is really a life skill that
everyone can benefit from especially in
a school context could can be applied to
any subjects or any discipline we have
examples in this year Summit where we
have Educators applying design mindsets
to redesigning the curriculum for
students
[Music]
design mindset allows us to connect the
dots between the challenges the
struggles the disappointments of today
and this more optimistic future we
challenge assumptions we say no to the
way things have always been done and we
find a more powerful Way Forward uh
design is for everyone not just for
designers and regardless of where you
find yourself even today as a student uh
you would find design really helpful and
helping you to think differently about
the challenges that you face in school
and also outside of
school we're going to explore themes
around creativity and also design and
how that can be built into the education
system I will be exploring with everyone
how to weave design thinking and
computational thinking uh into classroom
activities we'll be looking at how every
single one of us has a designer within
us and really that it starts with our
minds so we'll be building different
elements of a designer's mindset that
will help you with problem solving and
building your creativity no matter where
you are or how old you
[Music]
are